This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. Like millions of people around the world, Stanford economist Nicholas Bloom has been working from home since March. Instead of a university classroom, he now uses a spare bedroom. And sometimes, one of his four kids pops in while he does meetings over Zoom. He'll never forget this one time back in May. He was on a very important call with some business executives trying to help them with the research project.
这里是《Hidden Brain》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔。和全球数以百万计的人一样，斯坦福大学经济学家尼古拉斯·布鲁姆自三月以来一直在家办公。他现在不再使用大学教室，而是用一间空余的卧室办公。有时，当他通过Zoom开会时，他的四个孩子中的一个会突然闯进来。他永远不会忘记五月份发生的那件事。当时他正在与一些企业高管进行一次非常重要的通话，试图帮助他们完成研究项目。
About 20 minutes into the call, this happened. It was two of my kids starting their daily practice on the bagpokes. I was thinking, oh no, no, now is not the time. I had to like say quickly to Evan and meet him, I'm sorry, there's something going on in the background, mute myself and like run into the toilet. Ah, to take the rest of the meeting in there, because it was the only place that was quite enough.
通话进行了大约20分钟，发生了这样的事。我的两个孩子开始练习他们的日常乐器演奏。我当时心想，噢不，不，现在可不是时候。我不得不赶紧对埃文说让他静音，我说抱歉，背景里有点动静，然后把自己静音，像跑进厕所一样。啊，在里面完成剩下的会议，因为那是唯一足够安静的地方。
And our house isn't that big, and the sand proofing is just dreadful. It was the only place that was quite enough. And our house isn't that big, and the soundproofing is just dreadful. The toilet's about the only sound bunkered room, so I'm sure I'll be back in there again taking calls. Probably many calls, because Nick is an expert on the economic, cultural, and social implications of working from home. And now, in an almost surreal twist, he's living his research day in and day out. Just like the rest of us. So, is working from home working? So many people said, you know, we thought we'd be great at this, we thought we could deal with it. I thought I was mentally strong, I didn't like many of my employees, but I realized after three or four months,
我们的房子没那么大，隔音效果简直太糟糕了。那是唯一足够安静的地方。我们的房子没那么大，隔音效果简直太糟糕了。厕所几乎是唯一隔音的房间，所以我肯定还会再回到那里去接电话。可能会有很多电话，因为尼克是居家办公在经济、文化和社会影响方面的专家。现在，在一个近乎超现实的转折中，他日复一日地亲身实践着他的研究。就像我们其他人一样。那么，居家办公真的有效吗？很多人说，你知道，我们以为我们会很擅长这个，我们以为我们能应付得来。我以为我在心理上很强大，我不喜欢我的许多员工，但我三四个月后意识到，
maybe I didn't miss them. The psychological challenges and the possibilities of working from home this week on Hidden Brain. Before economist Nick Bloom became a professor at Stanford. He walked in London for a consulting company. He often worked from home and back then his co-workers made a lot of assumptions about what he did all day. I know there was endless joking about working from home, shurking from home, working remotely, working.
也许我并不想念他们。本周《Hidden Brain》将探讨居家办公的心理挑战和可能性。在经济学家尼克·布鲁姆成为斯坦福大学教授之前。他在伦敦的一家咨询公司工作。他经常在家办公，那时他的同事对他整天在做什么有很多假设。我知道关于居家办公、在家偷懒、远程办公、工作，有无休止的玩笑。
So they would wind me up and claim I was watching as old fashioned black and white, you know, TV movies that were on during the day, I was watching the cricket being British, but I honestly, I promise you, I was working, but it didn't feel like other people thought that was true. You probably had the cricket in the background though, didn't you? Yeah, I mean, I have to say, I'm not a big fan of cricket unless it comes to revising for my exams, during which point the cricket became fascinating, because you know, it was like anything's fascinating compared to revising. The assumptions that people have long held about working from home you can see them reflected in our searches online. Some time ago Nick looked at what you see when you search for the phrase working from home on the web. You know I gave a few talks I have to say before COVID I did a bit of you know King from Home on the web. or being in just search, do an image search under the words working from home. And if you do that, I screen-shot it for it and showed it in the TEDx talk in 2017. And I showed the top 15 hits that took, you know, the top two rows of images.
所以他们会捉弄我，声称我白天在看老式的黑白电视电影，或者在看板球比赛，因为我是英国人。但我诚实地向你保证，我是在工作，但其他人似乎并不相信这是真的。你当时背景里肯定放着板球比赛吧，对吧？是的，我不得不说，我不是板球的忠实粉丝，除非是为了复习考试，那时候板球变得非常迷人，因为你知道，相比于复习，任何事情都显得很有趣。人们长期以来对居家办公的假设，你可以从我们的在线搜索中看到。前段时间，尼克查看了你在网上搜索“居家办公”这个词组时会看到什么。你知道，在新冠疫情之前，我做过几次演讲，我不得不说，我做过一点点关于居家办公的搜索，或者只是做个图片搜索，输入“居家办公”这几个字。如果你这样做，我截了图，并在2017年的TEDx演讲中展示了它。我展示了前15个搜索结果，也就是前两排图片。
And they were basically naked people, cartoons, people juggling babies on their lap. They're honestly out of the 15, there are only two that were positive images. There were 13 that were just... They were like terrible. The worst was a guy in the Tarkuzzi drinking champagne, just it was so negatively viewed. So some years ago, and this is long before the COVID pandemic hit us, a new story broke about a certain company in Silicon Valley. Listen to this clip from NBC's Today Show.
它们基本上是裸体的人、卡通人物、膝盖上抱着婴儿的人。说实话，这15张图片里，只有两张是积极的。有13张简直是……它们太糟糕了。最糟糕的是一个在按摩浴缸里喝香槟的家伙，它被看待得太负面了。所以几年前，也就是在新冠疫情爆发很久之前，硅谷的一家公司爆出了一则新闻。听听NBC《今日秀》的这段剪辑。
Discrentled employees leaked an internal memo from human resources that bands tell a commuting, saying, some of the best decisions and insights come from hallway and cafeteria discussions, meeting new people and impromptu team meetings. Speed and quality are often sacrificed when we work from home. So Nick tell me why Yahoo CEO, Marissa Mayor wanted to cancel the company's policy to allow employees to work from home. Sure. She took over in Chusina's, you know, some of us to turn around the company.
不满的员工泄露了一份来自人力资源部的内部备忘录，禁止远程办公，称一些最好的决策和见解来自于走廊和自助餐厅的讨论、结识新朋友以及即兴的团队会议。当我们居家办公时，速度和质量往往会受到牺牲。那么尼克，告诉我为什么雅虎首席执行官玛丽莎·梅耶尔想要取消公司允许员工居家办公的政策？当然。她接手时，你知道，我们中的一些人去扭转公司局面。
And she said not long into her tenure there. She discovered there's a whole group of people that were working from home. But many of them were just not logging in the entire day. There wasn't much assessment what was going on. It was clear, well, while some of them are doing really well, others were basically using it as a way to take an extended holiday. And you know what's kind of intriguing,
她在任职不久后说。她发现有一大群人在家办公。但他们中的许多人整天根本没有登录。对正在发生的事情没有太多的评估。很明显，虽然他们中有些人做得很好，但其他人基本上把它当作一种延长假期的方式。你知道，这有点耐人寻味，
when I spoke to her, she said, look, working from home can be great, but you need a performance evaluation system. You need to make sure that the people at home are actually working rather than goofing off. And she said at that point, we didn't have an in Yahoo. So I basically, you know, temporarily pause the working at home scheme until we got a performance system in
当我与她交谈时，她说，看，居家办公可以很棒，但你需要一个绩效评估系统。你需要确保在家的人确实在工作，而不是在偷懒。她说当时我们在雅虎没有这个系统。所以我基本上，你知道，暂时暂停了居家办公计划，直到我们有了绩效系统，
and then you know, relaxed it back a bit. But yes, it generated a storm of media back in our 2013. I still remember now. Yeah. So you've done research into whether Marissa Mayor was right generated a storm of media back in our 2013. I still remember now. Yeah. So you've done research into whether Marissa Mayer was right in terms of the effects of working from home on productivity. But before we get to the science,
然后，你知道，稍微放宽了一点。但是的，它在2013年引发了一场媒体风暴。我现在还记得。是的。所以你研究过玛丽莎·梅耶尔在居家办公对生产力影响方面是否正确。但在我们进入科学层面之前，
I want to talk a moment about the history of how we got to these attitudes about working from home. So long before COVID, people who didn't work in an office were seen as the exception. But what's interesting is that when you look down history, most people would have found it odd to work anywhere other than their homes. Yeah, you're exactly right. You know, what's happened now is made, you know, history so odd. So if you go back to, you know, 1750, just on the eve of the Industrial Revolution in the UK,
我想花点时间谈谈我们对居家办公这些态度的历史由来。在新冠疫情之前很久，不在办公室工作的人被视为例外。但有趣的是，当你回顾历史时，大多数人会觉得在家里以外的任何地方工作都很奇怪。是的，你说得完全对。你知道，现在发生的事情让历史变得如此奇怪。所以如果你回到1750年，就在英国工业革命前夕，
basically we all worked at home. We worked in the fields or occasionally a skilled craftsman, but no one was really working anywhere else than home. And then office work or factory work really started off with offices. So places that Manchester in the UK started to have industrial machinery, and of course, to do that, you needed scale buildings, and you know,
基本上我们都在家里工作。我们在田里干活，或者偶尔是熟练的工匠，但没有人真正在家以外的地方工作。然后办公室工作或工厂工作真正开始于办公室。所以像英国曼彻斯特这样的地方开始有了工业机械，当然，要做到这一点，你需要大型建筑，而且你知道，
people needed to start to commute. But I should point out, back then, in 1800, when you talk about commuting, you were walking to the factory that was really not that far away. The major offices started around 1900 when big companies had growing amounts of paperwork and they just have vast halls full of clerks that would come in and process piles of paper. And, you know, oddly enough, despite the complete change in technology over the next, you know, 120 years up until, you know, January of this year, we were still very much focused on coming into the office on a kind of nine to five schedule. And isn't it interesting that along the way, the cultural norms and psychological norms
人们开始需要通勤。但我应该指出，那时，在1800年，当你谈论通勤时，你是步行去工厂，那真的离得不远。主要的办公室工作始于1900年左右，当时大公司有越来越多的文书工作，他们只是有巨大的大厅，里面坐满了文员，他们会进来处理成堆的文件。而且，奇怪的是，尽管在接下来的120年里，直到今年一月，技术发生了彻底的改变，我们仍然非常专注于以九到五的时间表来到办公室。有趣的是，在此过程中，文化规范和心理规范
sort of evolved with these workplace arrangements, so that people who work from home came to be seen as less ambitious or less employable, less talented maybe, and others became almost declassay to be working from home. Exactly. It's one of those things. Economists might call it a generally equilibrium effect, which means even if one firm figured out working from home was great, it was hard for them to change it alone because there's a negative stigma.
随着这些工作场所的安排而演变，以至于居家办公的人被视为缺乏雄心、缺乏就业能力或缺乏才华，其他人甚至认为居家办公几乎是不入流的。确实。这是经济学家可能称之为“一般均衡效应”的事情之一，这意味着即使一家公司发现居家办公很棒，他们也很难独自改变它，因为存在负面污名。
And no employee wants to have it maybe on their CV that they worked at home for years, because other firms think it is bad. And so yeah, exactly right. I mean, just to be clear, the four things we need for working from home are internet, broadband, laptops, and video calls. And all of them have been around since the mid 2000 so the last one to come out was video calls
而且没有员工愿意在简历上写着他们在家工作了多年，因为其他公司认为这很糟糕。所以是的，完全正确。我的意思是，为了明确起见，我们居家办公需要的四样东西是互联网、宽带、笔记本电脑和视频通话。它们从2000年代中期就存在了，最后一个出现的是视频通话，
and that was really the dawn of Skype Hello Can you hear me? So Skype comes out in 2003 It's me, I'm in Cal It's kind of mainstream by 2005-06 Hello Hey
那真的是Skype的黎明。你好，你能听到我说话吗？所以Skype在2003年出现。是我，我在加州。到2005-06年它已经成为主流。你好，嘿。
So really for probably 15 years now we could have effectively worked from home but it was the whole social norms that up until now I've held us back How are you? So typical of me to talk about myself. I'm sorry And this is enormous inertia in the system because you know We've built entire cities around the idea that there's going to be this urban core where people work and suburbs where people live. We built highways and public transit systems to ferry people from residential neighborhoods to
所以实际上可能已经有15年了，我们可以有效地居家办公，但直到现在，整个社会规范一直阻碍着我们。你好吗？谈论我自己真是我的典型作风。我很抱歉。系统中有巨大的惯性，因为你知道，我们围绕着这样一个理念建立了整个城市：有一个人们工作的城市核心，以及人们居住的郊区。我们修建了高速公路和公共交通系统，将人们从住宅区运送到
commercial neighborhoods. It's almost as if once that initial model separating the workplace from the home got fixed in people's minds, there was an inertia that got built up around it that became essentially unstoppable. Yes, exactly. I mean, I think one big change post-COVID, there's going to be driven both by working from home. And also the other issue is social distancing. So just to be clear, high rises, skyscrapers in the center of cities have two amazingly tough challenges. One is getting people to the front door.
商业区。几乎就像一旦那种将工作场所与家庭分开的初始模式在人们心中固定下来，围绕它建立起来的惯性就变得基本上不可阻挡了。是的，完全正确。我的意思是，我认为新冠疫情后的一大变化将由居家办公驱动。另一个问题是社交距离。所以为了明确起见，市中心的高层建筑、摩天大楼面临两个极其严峻的挑战。一个是让人到达前门。
So you think of Manhattan or London or Shanghai or Mumbai. You've got to get people there, and that involves often the subway of the tube. And that's almost, it's basically impossible to to do and the second is getting them from the front door to their office on the 20th floor which involves using the elevator. So both of those are huge challenges. So I think in future a lot of that real estate is probably going to be converted into apartments and it's going to be, you know, the price of it's going to drop a lot and it's going to attract conversion into apartments. So we're going to have much more mixed living modes whereby those
所以你想到曼哈顿、伦敦、上海或孟买。你必须让人到达那里，这通常涉及地铁。这几乎是不可能做到的，第二个是让他们从前门到达20楼的办公室，这涉及使用电梯。所以这两者都是巨大的挑战。所以我认为未来很多房地产可能会被改造成公寓，它的价格可能会大幅下降，并将吸引改造成公寓。所以我们将有更多混合的生活模式，
skyscrapers aren't all offices and we don't all live out in the suburbs. Instead, you know, there's more people living in their centre on lower rents and there's less commuting because it's the only way we're going to be able to shape it. And of course, included in that less-commeeting, will be more working from home. When we come back, Nick Bloom tells us about his unusual experiment at a Chinese travel agency, where half of the workers stayed in the office, and half were allowed to work from home. We did a lot of interviews, and I just said it's really depressing. Or they felt victim to one of the three great enemies of working from home. We did a lot of interviews and they just said it's really depressing. Or they felt victim to one of the three great enemies of working from home, the bad, the
摩天大楼不全是办公室，我们也不都住在郊区。相反，你知道，有更多的人以较低的租金住在市中心，通勤也减少了，因为这是我们能够塑造它的唯一方式。当然，包括在那种减少通勤中的，将是更多的居家办公。当我们回来时，尼克·布鲁姆将告诉我们他在一家中国旅行社进行的不同寻常的实验，那里一半的员工留在办公室，另一半被允许居家办公。我们做了很多采访，他们只是说这真的很令人沮丧。或者他们成为了居家办公三大敌人的受害者。我们做了很多采访，他们只是说这真的很令人沮丧。或者他们成为了居家办公三大敌人的受害者，床、
fridge or the television. Nick Bloom is a researcher at Stanford University. For years, he has studied the phenomenon of working from home and asked a deceptively simple question. Are people more productive or less productive when they work from home and asked a deceptively simple question. Are people more productive or less productive when they work from home? Nick, you were teaching a class at Stanford in 2010 and you had a student in the class from China and you got a chatting with him. He told you about a problem his company was having back in China. What was the problem? having back in China, what was the problem?
冰箱或电视。尼克·布鲁姆是斯坦福大学的研究员。多年来，他研究了居家办公的现象，并提出了一个看似简单的问题。当人们居家办公时，他们的生产力是更高还是更低？尼克，你2010年在斯坦福教书，班里有一个来自中国的学生，你和他聊了起来。他告诉了你他的公司在中国遇到的一个问题。是什么问题？
You know, as a backstop, you know, the situation was pretty weird. I was teaching a PhD, a graduate economics class in Stanford, and I have about, you know, 15 to 20 students in the class. One of them I figured out relatively soon. Maybe, you know, a third of the way into the course was James Leang from talking to him, who was the CEO and co-founder of this huge
你知道，作为背景，情况相当奇怪。我在斯坦福教一门博士研究生经济学课程，班里大约有15到20名学生。我相对较快地发现其中一个。也许在课程进行到三分之一时，通过交谈，我知道他是詹姆斯·梁，他是这家巨大的
Chinese travel agent and he said that they were growing really fast doing very well but they were based at Changhai and their challenge was office space in Changhai was incredibly expensive and so they wanted to figure out how to grow without you know sinking vast amounts of money into ever increasing size of expensive offices and so they were thinking about a working-from-home program. So you decided to work with this Chinese company called C-Trip to find out whether working-from-home was good or bad in terms of productivity. And you did more than just simply conduct a survey, you decided to conduct an experiment. Yes, you know, the great thing was because James is a PhD economics student.
中国旅行社的首席执行官兼联合创始人。他说他们发展得非常快，做得很好，但他们总部在上海，他们的挑战是上海的办公空间极其昂贵，所以他们想弄清楚如何在不投入巨额资金购买越来越大的昂贵办公室的情况下实现增长，所以他们正在考虑一个居家办公计划。所以你决定与这家名为携程的中国公司合作，找出居家办公在生产力方面是好是坏。你做的不仅仅是进行调查，你决定进行一项实验。是的，你知道，最棒的是因为詹姆斯是经济学博士生。
He was open to what's called doing a randomized control trial. So quite formally, they went to Incytrip, they got two divisions, hotel and airfare. There are about a thousand people in them and they asked them who wants to work from home. You know, amazingly, we're not interestingly, maybe as much as amazing, only a half of them volunteered. It is to be clean. You know, a lot of people don't want to work from home. So the volunteers tended to be slightly older,
他愿意进行所谓的随机对照试验。所以非常正式地，他们去了携程，他们有两个部门，酒店和机票。里面大约有一千人，他们问谁想居家办公。你知道，令人惊讶的是，或者说有趣的是，也许没那么令人惊讶，只有一半人自愿参加。为了明确起见。你知道，很多人不想居家办公。所以志愿者往往稍微年长一点，
more like to have kids live further away. But then they took these 500 volunteers and had a full more randomization. So James, on C-trip TV, drew a ping pong ball out of an earner and it said even, so it meant people with even birthdays, if you were born on the second, fourth, sixth, eighth, tenth, etc. of the month, you were in the treatment sample, so you actually got to work from home for four days a week for the next nine months. And if you're odd like me, I'm the fifth of me, you were the control group and you were remained in the office for the next nine months.
更有可能有孩子，住得更远。但随后他们选取了这500名志愿者，并进行了完全的随机化。所以詹姆斯在携程电视上从一个罐子里抽出了一个乒乓球，上面写着偶数，这意味着生日是偶数的人，如果你出生在每月的2号、4号、6号、8号、10号等，你就在实验样本中，所以你在接下来的九个月里实际上可以每周居家办公四天。如果你像我一样是奇数，我是5号，你就是对照组，在接下来的九个月里留在办公室。
A few other notes about the experiment. For the workers who went home four days a week, they all came into the office on the fifth day. That was when they did things that were best to do in person, like team meetings and trainings. And managers were always in the office. The main worry for C-Trip was the fear that all companies seemed to have, that the remote employees would get distracted and not be productive. But C-Trip had a plan to deal with that.
关于实验还有几点说明。对于每周回家四天的员工，他们都在第五天来到办公室。那是他们做最适合亲自完成的事情的时候，比如团队会议和培训。经理们总是待在办公室。携程的主要担忧是所有公司似乎都有的恐惧，即远程员工会分心，生产力不高。但携程有一个应对计划。
If they had declines in productivity, they figured that those would be offset by the huge savings in rent. In fact, this calculation was one of the reasons they agreed to run the experiment in the first place. To see how many dollars they saved on rent versus how many dollars they might lose on productivity. And then the results came in. So you know it was the results were honestly amazing and this is why you know it was so valuable to have nine months because an issue you were thinking this can't be
如果他们的生产力下降，他们认为这些会被租金的巨大节省所抵消。事实上，这个计算是他们同意进行实验的原因之一。看看他们在租金上节省了多少美元，对比他们在生产力上可能损失了多少美元。然后结果出来了。所以你知道，结果老实说令人惊叹，这就是为什么拥有九个月的时间如此有价值，因为起初你认为这不可能是
true. What you saw was the working from home employees were 13% more productive than the people in the office. Just to be clear, that is an enormous uplift. That's almost a day extra a week, simply from having the same people and the same team doing the same job, which is answering telephone calls, dealing with the customer complaints, taking bookings, etc. Now working at home rather than the office. And did they actually calculate a dollar figure in terms of increased productivity, not just from the increased productivity but from the savings on rent?
真的。你看到的是居家办公的员工比办公室里的人生产力高出13%。为了明确起见，这是一个巨大的提升。这几乎相当于每周多工作一天，仅仅是因为拥有相同的人和相同的团队做相同的工作，也就是接听电话、处理客户投诉、预订等。现在是在家工作而不是在办公室。他们是否真的计算出了生产力提高方面的美元数字，不仅是生产力提高，还有租金节省？
Yes, so they estimated they saved around $2,000 per employee per year from working from home. And you know, Cedric was like, as you can imagine, was incredibly positive about this and at the end of the experiment announced they're rolling the scheme out to the entire company. So now employees who really hated working from home, were they allowed to come back and start working
是的，所以他们估计通过居家办公，每位员工每年节省了大约2000美元。而且你知道，携程正如你所想象的那样，对此非常积极，并在实验结束时宣布将该计划推广到整个公司。所以现在那些真的很讨厌居家办公的员工，他们被允许回来并开始在
out of the office? Yes, a striking finding. Again, totally unexpected was, there are two things, two elements. One is initially they offered to a thousand employees, only 500 wanted to work from home. So our view would have been, honestly, many more people have taken out, but a lot of people do not want to work from home. One reason is, the people that want to come to the office are young and single, as we know, in the US about a third of people meet their spouse in the workplace. Something similar is true in China. The other thing is, after the end of the nine months experiment, remembering everyone
办公室工作吗？是的，一个惊人的发现。同样，完全出乎意料的是，有两件事，两个要素。一是最初他们提供给一千名员工，只有500人想居家办公。所以我们的观点老实说，会有更多人接受，但很多人不想居家办公。一个原因是，想来办公室的人年轻且单身，正如我们所知，在美国大约三分之一的人在工作场所遇到他们的配偶。在中国也有类似的情况。另一件事是，在九个月实验结束后，记住实验中的每个人都自愿参加了，大约一半抽中居家办公的人实际上改变了主意，决定回到办公室。而对照组的所有人九个月前都自愿参加了，只是没抽中，但此时，你被允许做任何他们想做的事。只有三分之一的人最终真的回家了。所以人们在尝试过之后，实际上有很大一部分人反对每周居家办公四到五天，这再次非常令人惊讶，你认为，你知道员工部分是按绩效支付报酬的，所以既然他们在家的表现提高了13%，他们的工资也上涨了，但即便如此，
in the experiment and volunteered, around half of the people that won the lottery to work from home, actually changed their minds and decided to come back in the office. And the control group who'd all volunteered, you know, nine months ago, it just lost the lottery, but at this point, you're allowed to do whatever they want. Only a third of them actually ended up going home. So there was a huge move away actually after people had tried it out against working from home for out of five days a week, which again was very surprisingly thought, you know employees are partly paid on performance so since they're performing 13% more at home their pay has gone up but even so
他们中的大量人，超过一半的人在投票，你知道用脚投票，因为他们被要求主动回到办公室，承担所有相关的通勤成本和麻烦。尼克，这里面难道没有真正的讽刺吗，公司认为人们的生产力会降低，但事实上，人们的生产力反而更高了，而且人们以为他们想居家办公，但一旦他们真的这样做了，他们实际上想回到工作岗位。是的，你知道，这回到了，我认为，我们真正需要和员工平均想要的是一种混合。所以携程当时只提供每周在家四到五天。我想你知道，我实际上最近又联系了携程。如果你转向一个他们可以每周居家办公一两天系统，那会更受欢迎。现在出于后勤原因，他们没有提供这一点。但大多数员工，我们在实验中也看到了这一点，我应该说，在前两三个月，他们真的很开心，他们对此非常积极。但随着时间的推移，我们只是收到越来越多关于孤独的报告和投诉，日复一日地待在家里工作真的很令人沮丧。你是一个人。所以当九个月结束时，
large numbers of them more than half of them were voting in sense, you know voting with their feet because they are asked to actively come back into the office with all the commute costs and hassle that involved. Isn't there a real irony here, Nick, which is that the company thought that people were going to be less productive, but in fact, people turned out to be more productive, and people thought they wanted to work from home, but once they actually did, they actually wanted to come back to work. Yes, you know, it comes back to, I think, what we really need and what employees want on
你知道，很多人相当惊讶，但他们说，我受不了这个。我想，我们做了很多采访，顺便说一句，很多焦点小组访谈，他们只是说这真的很令人沮丧。或者他们成为了居家办公三大敌人的受害者，床、冰箱或电视。所以基本上出了点问题。
average is a mix. So C-trip at that point was only offering four out of five days a week at home. I think you know I've actually again caught up with C-trip very recently. If you'd moved to a system where they could have worked from home one or two days a week, that would have been far more popular. Now for the logistical reasons they didn't offer that. But most employees, and we saw this in the experiment, I should say, for the first two or three months, they were really happy, they're very positive on it. But as time went on, we just got increasing reports and complaints about loneliness and it's very depressing being at home day in day out, working there. You're on your own. And so by the time it came to the end of nine months,
他们说，看，救救我，让我离开这里。我想回到办公室。我的意思是，这相当令人震惊，但我相信很多人可以理解，你知道，对我来说，我真的很想念我的同事。我喜欢待在家里，你知道，我和妻子还有四个孩子住在一起，但这有点让人感到孤立。我很乐意回到办公室，至少每周两三天，这和我们在携程看到的情况一样。所以换句话说，部分你所看到的是，居家办公可能带来的好处，你知道，无论你送谁回家，都有一些优势，
you know, many people were quite surprised, but they said, I can't, I can't hack this. I want to, we did a lot of interviews, by the way, a lot of focus group interviews, and they just said it's really depressing. Or they fell victim to one of the three great enemies of working from home, the bed, the fridge, or the television. So something basically went wrong.
当然是在节省办公空间方面。但可能是最适合居家办公的人是那些真正想居家办公的人。所以从员工的角度来看，一定程度的灵活性可能是生产力等式的一部分。是的，完全正确。我的意思是，我从这个实验以及我一直在做的更近期的工作中得出的两点是选择和灵活性的重要性。所以事实证明在选择上，人们有完全不同的观点，而且很难
And they said, look, save me, get me out of here. I want to come back to the office. I mean, it's quite astounding, but I'm sure many people can enter those, you know, for me, I'm really missing my colleagues. I like being at home, you know, I live with my wife and four kids, but it kind of gets isolating. I'd loved to go back into the office in at least for two, three days a week, and that's the same thing we saw in Cetra. So in other words, partly what you're seeing is that they might be benefits from working from home that are just, you know, regardless of who you send home, there are some advantages,
知道，你知道，人们的观点是什么。很大程度上取决于他们的家庭环境如何。他们有空间吗，空余房间？你知道，他们想待在家里吗？公寓好吗？然后在灵活性上，实际上很难说。所以在携程，我们只是在焦点小组中发现，很多人说，你知道，我们以为我们会很擅长这个，我们以为我们能应付得来，我以为我在心理上很强大，我不觉得，你知道，我不喜欢我的许多员工，所以我实际上想回家，但我意识到在，你知道，三四个月后，也许我确实想念他们。这就像
certainly in terms of saving on office space. But it may be that the people who actually are best suited to working from home are the people who actually want to be working from home. So some amount of flexibility from the point of view of the employees might be part of the productivity equation. Yes, exactly. I mean, the two things I took out of this and from more recent work I've been doing is the importance of choice and flexibility. So it turns out on choice, people have just really different views and it's very
那句老话“小别胜新婚”，这似乎是真的。你知道，尽管很难想象，我相信现在外面有些人会想，即使是会计部那个真的很烦人的托尼，也许我会有点想他，等等。这似乎就是我们在携程和中国看到的情况。而且也许香槟和按摩浴缸在四个月后开始变得陈旧。你在携程实验中关于离职率也有一些有趣的发现。告诉我关于留住员工方面发生了什么，你发现了什么。是的，另一个惊人的发现是，居家办公的人离职率下降了一半。所以公司收集了很多调查，他们在调查中报告说更快乐。
hard to know, you know, what people's views are. Depends a lot on what their home's circumstances are like. Do they have space, spare room? You know, do they want to be at home? Is there a apartment nice? And then on flexibility, it's actually really hard to tell. So in C-Trip, we just discovered in the focus groups, so many people said, you know, we thought we'd be great at this, we thought we could deal with it, I thought I was mentally strong, I didn't feel like, you know, I didn't like many of my employees, so I actually wanted to go home, but I realized after, you know, three or four months, maybe I did miss them. It's like
但我有时有点怀疑。我不知道，很难知道公司是在调查对公司的回应，员工对公司。但更重要的事情是用脚投票。所以携程的员工离职率大约是50%。事实证明，这与英国、美国、澳大利亚等许多国家的平均水平几乎相同，50%左右是正常的。所以大多数人在跳槽前会在一份工作中待大约两年。对于居家办公的员工，他们的离职率
that old saying absence makes the heart grow thunder and it seemed to be true. You know, as hard as it is to imagine, I'm sure there are some people out there now thinking, even that really annoying guy Tony in accounts, maybe I'll miss him a bit, etc. That seemed to be what we're seeing with C-trip and China. And also maybe the champagne and the jacuzzi starts to get old after four months. You also had some interesting findings from the C-Trip experiment when it came to quit rates. Tell me what happened in terms of retaining employees what you found. Yeah, another striking finding was quit rates fell by half for the people that work from home. So the firm collects a lot of surveys and they reported in the survey so far happier.
从50%减半降至25%，这对公司来说当然是一个巨大的优势，因为它避免了招聘、培训和让人们上手的大部分痛苦，结果他们却离职了。所以我很好奇，当人们想到居家办公的旧负面刻板印象时，人们是否忘记了居家办公的人容易分心，他们会被冰箱
But I'm sometimes slightly skeptical. I don't know whether it's hard to know the firms were surveying a response to the firm, the employees to the firm. But the much more important thing is the voting with their feet. So C-trip has about a 50% quick rate for its employees. It turns out that's almost identical to the average in the UK. US Australia, many countries, 50% about normal. So most people stay about two years in a job before moving on. For the working from home employees, their quick rates
和电视和床分散注意力。他们实际上忘记了工作场所也是分心的来源。工作场所通常，你知道，有多种事情在发生。有Slack频道告诉你另一层楼正在分发免费食物，你知道，有人在过生日。
halved from 50% down to 25%, which of course with the company was a huge upside because it avoided a large chunk of the pain of hiring and training and getting people out to speed just for them to then quit. So I'm wondering if one of the things that people forget when they think about the old negative stereotypes of working from home that people are easily distracted, they're going to be distracted by the fridge
工作场所也不是一个高度专注、集中的环境。不，完全正确。所以为了解释居家办公带来的13%的生产力提高，其中大约三分之一是居家员工每分钟的生产力更高。这完全是因为家平均来说实际上干扰更少。从采访中，出现了一些搞笑的故事。我最喜欢的是那个女人说的，当我在办公室时，太让人分心了。
and the TV and the bed. That they actually forget the workplace is also a source of distraction. The workplace is often, you know, there are multiple things going on. There are slack channels that tell you about the free food that's being given away on another floor of the building and you know, there's someone's birthday going on.
我隔壁隔间的女人剪她的脚趾甲。噢，她确实做了这件事，你知道，这个脚趾甲剪，她把它剪在桌子下面。她说，在桌子下面，她说，她以为我没注意到，但我告诉你，我注意到了，我注意到这很恶心。你知道，有那个。有世界杯抽奖的故事，休息室里有蛋糕，有些男朋友和女朋友分手了，你知道你可以想象，所以家，你说得完全对，家会让人分心，但事实证明办公室明显更让人分心，所以实际上你至少在这个实验中每分钟可以更高效地工作。
It's not as if the workplace is a highly focused, concentrating environment either. No, exactly right. So just to explain, for the 13% higher productivity from working from home, about a third of that was the home-based employees who are more productive per minute. And that's entirely because home is on average actually less distracting. From the interviews, there are some hilarious stories that come up. My favorite was the woman that said, when I'm in the office, it's so distracting.
所以我理解通过携程的研究，你可以每分钟更高效地工作。至少在这个实验中。所以我理解通过携程的研究，一些居家办公的人想回来，也许是因为他们觉得自己在与一直待在办公室的同事相比处于劣势。也许同事们得到了更多与老板面对面的时间。所以在某种程度上，实验并没有
The woman in the cubicle next to me clips her toenails. Oh, she did exactly this, you know, this toenail clip up and she clips it under the table. And she said, under the desk, she said, she thinks, I don't notice, but I tell you, I notice, I notice it's disgusting. You know, there's that. There are stories of World Cup Cup sweepstakes of there's a cake in the breakout room Some of these boyfriend and girlfriend have left you know you can imagine so Home you're exactly right home is distracting, but the office is turns out to be significantly more distracting and so actually you can work more efficiently per minute at least in this experiment
消除居家办公不如办公室工作的社会规范。它基本上把它作为一个短期实验呈现出来。是的，所以我说居家办公实验的一个阴暗面是居家办公人员晋升率的下降。所以如果你控制绩效，记住在家的人生产力高出16%。他们本应以更快的速度晋升。事实证明，他们的晋升速度较慢。事实上，他们最终的晋升率大约是在家工作的人与在办公室工作的人的一半。
So I understand with the with the C-Trep study you can walk more efficiently per minute. At least in this experiment. So I understand with the C-Trep study, some people who were working from home wanted to come back, perhaps because they felt like they were losing out to colleagues who were in the office all the time. Maybe the colleagues were getting more face time with the bosses. So in some ways the experiment didn't do,
所以晋升率大幅下降。当我们问他们时，结果发现有几个因素。为什么？一是你居家办公，你被遗忘了。所以这是一个严重的缺点，你在一个15人的团队中，假设有3个人居家办公，其余人在办公室，你可能会被忽略。另一件棘手的事情是，当你与携程交谈时，他们说，
it didn't do away with the social norm that working from home was inferior It basically laid it out as a short-term experiment Yes, so the one dark side I'd say of working from home from the experiment was the drop in promotion rates for people working from home So if you control for performance remember the people at home will 16% will be productive They should have been promoted at a much faster rate. And it turns out they were promoted less rapidly. In fact, they're roughly their eventual promotion rate was roughly half for those at home versus at the office.
嗯，晋升的一部分是了解你的同事和了解公司文化等。这确实来自于在办公室，在周围吃午餐和喝咖啡。所以，你知道，这有点不好。在家额外生产力的一部分是因为花在喝咖啡闲聊上的时间少了，
So there's a huge drop in promotions. And when we asked them, it turned out looking into there's a couple of factors. Why? One is you're working from home, you're forgotten about. And so that's a serious downside that you're in a team of 15 and let's have a three of you working from home, the rest of the office, you can be passed over. The other thing that was tricky to how to deal with, when you spoke to C-trip, they said,
但事实证明，其中一些闲聊相当有用。那么，当数亿人不是选择居家办公，而是全球大流行突然为他们做出这个选择时，会发生什么。接下来。新冠疫情重塑了世界。数十万人死亡，数百万人失业。几乎在一夜之间，在许多国家，居家办公不再是例外，不再
well, part of being promoted is knowing your colleagues and knowing about the firm culture, et cetera. And that does come from being in the office and having lunch and coffees around. So, you know, it's a bit of a bad. Some of the extra productivities at home is because there's plenty less time chitchatting over coffee,
是福利，而只是一个新常态。尼克，你多年来一直在宣扬居家办公的优点。我很好奇这感觉如何。尼克，你多年来一直在宣扬居家办公的优点。我很好奇这感觉如何。你并没有真正推动这一点，然后突然之间，砰，成千上万的公司和数百万人一夜之间开始这样做。你感到措手不及吗？是的，这是一种奇怪的经历。
but some of that chitchat turns out to be pretty useful. So what happens when hundreds of millions of people don't make a choice to work from home, but when a global pandemic suddenly makes that choice for them. That's next. The COVID-19 pandemic has reshaped the world. Hundreds of thousands have died and millions have lost their jobs. Virtually overnight, working from home in many countries has become not an exception, not
前几天我做了一些事情，查看了美国报纸中“居家办公”这个词的频率。所以我查看了美国前50大报纸，它在2020年1月到4月之间上升了12000%。所以是的，我的意思是，我对此很着迷，我正在经历它。研究你和你所有朋友正在经历的事情是非常奇怪的。我所有的朋友和亲戚等都在经历完全相同的问题。我应该说，在美国目前，只有40%的人在居家办公。所以30%的人没有工作。30%的人在营业场所工作，通常是基本服务人员。但是
a perk, but just a new normal. Nick, you've been preaching the virtues of working from home for years. I'm curious what this feels like. Nick, you've been preaching the virtues of walking from home for years. I'm curious what this feels like. You don't really move the needle on that and then suddenly boom, thousands of companies and millions of people start doing it overnight. Have you suffered whiplash? Yeah, it is a weird experience.
对于我们这些居家办公的人来说，在许多方面，你实际上是幸运的少数，能够工作并能够安全地在家做这件事。嗯。所以，关于这五分之二的员工，这40%居家办公的员工，目前转变非常有趣的一点是，变化发生得如此突然且如此广泛，以至于它似乎一夜之间改变了规范。所以，Zoom通话、电子邮件和电话交谈现在是默认设置。它们不再是工作场所的二等公民。是的，完全正确。你知道，这很有趣。我正在和我在伦敦的一个朋友交谈，他为一家美国公司工作，他正试图在南非建立一个
I was doing something the other day looking at the frequency of the world working from home in US newspapers So I looked at the top 50 US newspapers and it went up 12,000 percent between January and April 2020 So yeah, it's I mean, I'm fascinated by I'm living it. It's very odd to be researching something that you and all your friends are living in I all my friends and relatives etc going through exactly the same issue. I should say that in the US currently, only 40% of people are working from home. So 30% of people are not working. And 30% of people are working on business premises, which are typically essential service workers. But
同一公司的子公司。他说他直到现在，他一直都在用Zoom，但他一直，你知道，或者无论什么Teams。他总是那个局外人，因为其他人都在房间里，而他通常是拨入的。他说突然之间，他感到和大家处于同一水平，每个人都在Zoom上。
for those of us that are working from home, in many ways, you're actually in the lucky minority that we're able to work and able to do this safely at home. Hmm. So, one of the things that's very interesting about the current shift for this two in five workers, this 40% of workers that are working from home, is that the changes happen so suddenly and is so widespread that it seems to have changed norms overnight. So, Zoom calls and emails and phone conversations are now the default. They no longer the second class citizen in the workplace. Yeah, exactly. You know, it's funny. I was talking to a friend of mine that lives in London and he works for US company and he's trying to set up a, you know, a startup of
我也有类似的反馈，实际上，我正在给美国的一个国家实验室做演讲，那里有人是残疾人。我们说，你说，你知道，在某些情况下，这对我是个很好的平衡，因为我很难去办公室再回来，但现在，你知道，都在Zoom上，身体在那里真的不重要了。所以它产生了一些不同寻常的效果，既有积极的也有消极的。事实上，你知道，我只想说一个最后的轶事。我正在和某人交谈，她创办了一家高科技公司，她在湾区创办了一家高科技公司。她出生在印度，来到这里并在这里创办了公司。
the same company subsidiary in South Africa. And he was saying he up until, you know, now he was always on Zoom, but he was always, you know, now he was always on Zoom, but he was always, you know, or whatever teams. He was always the other one out, in the sense that everyone else is in the room and he was typically dialing in. And he said suddenly, he felt on the level with everyone else that everyone was on Zoom.
她说，她注意到在Zoom上谁发言。这与亲自发言的人非常不同。她说，你知道，美国人在会议上非常大声。而且有一些文化和性别差异。当你进行视频通话时，它们非常不同。许多以前不发言的人现在感到有权发言，因为他们发现视频通话不那么令人生畏。非常有趣。我理解你已经
And I had a similar feedback, actually, I was giving a presentation to one of the national labs in the US and somebody there was disabled. And we're saying, you saying, you know, in some cases this has been a great level of for me because I struggled to get into the office and back, but now, you know, all on Zoom and being physically there really doesn't matter. So it has had some unusual effects, both positive and negative. And in fact, you know, I just won a final anecdote. I was talking to someone that starts a high tech run, she founded a high tech company out in the Bay Area. She was born in India and came over and started the company here.
事实上，我也收到过类似的反馈。当时我正在美国的一家国家实验室做演讲，那里有一位残障人士对我说，在某些情况下，这对我来说是一个很好的平衡器，因为我以前很难往返办公室，但现在都在Zoom上进行，身体是否在场其实并不重要。所以它产生了一些不同寻常的影响，既有积极的，也有消极的。事实上，我再讲最后一个轶事。我曾与一位在高科技领域创业的人交谈，她在湾区创办了一家高科技公司。她出生在印度，后来来到这里创办了这家公司。
And she was saying, she notices on Zoom who speaks up. It's quite different from who does it in person. And she was saying, you know, Americans are like, amazingly loud in meetings. And there's some cultural and gender differences. They're quite different when you're on video calls. A number of people that previously didn't spoke up have now felt actually empowered to talk because they find it less intimidating on a video call. Very interesting. I understand you've
她说，她注意到在Zoom上发言的人与面对面会议时大不相同。她说，美国人在会议上声音大得惊人。而且这其中还存在一些文化和性别差异。当进行视频通话时，情况就完全不同了。许多以前不发言的人现在感到有勇气发言了，因为他们觉得视频通话没那么令人生畏。非常有趣。我了解到你已经
completed a survey of nearly 2,000 Americans. Paint me a picture of the people who report making a successful switch to working from home and the people who can't or don't. So you know one huge factor is clearly education. So it's not that being educated makes you better working from home. It's that being educated means you're in the type of job that means you can probably work from home. So if we look at working from home jobs, they tend to be much more managerial professional. You can imagine that the kind of things that
完成了一项针对近2000名美国人的调查。请为我描绘一下那些报告称成功转型为居家办公的人，以及那些不能或没有这样做的人。你知道，一个巨大的因素显然是教育。所以，并不是说受过教育让你更擅长居家办公，而是受过教育意味着你所从事的工作类型可能允许你居家办公。因此，如果我们看看居家办公的工作，它们往往更偏向管理和专业性质。你可以想象，那些……
are typically done beforehand in the office and so it can be easily shifted home. If you look at say people with a high school degree or less, so those that left school, 16, 17, 18, their farm will like to be in retail, maybe it's in construction, manufacturing, the types of things you need to be on site. So, education has become an enormous divider actually in terms of who can work from home. The other couple of factors that we picked up on, again, kind of links to wealth and education is having functional internet. It's astounding, but only 65% of Americans in our survey report having internet connectivity
通常在办公室预先完成的事情，因此可以很容易地转移到家里。如果你看看那些只有高中学历或以下的人，也就是那些16、17、18岁就离开学校的人，他们的工作很可能是在零售业，也许是在建筑业、制造业，这些工作需要你在现场。所以，教育实际上已经成为谁能居家办公的一个巨大分水岭。我们注意到的另外几个因素，同样与财富和教育有关，那就是拥有功能性的互联网。这很令人震惊，但在我们的调查中，只有65%的美国人报告说拥有互联网连接……
good enough to run a video call, a high quality video call. So, for those of us that living in nice parts of cities, it seems totally standard. You have good internet, but a lot of poorer urban areas or rural areas, they have internet, but it flakes in and out, and so you can't really have video calls. The other thing is having space at home, so people have been able to make this a success, report having their own room that's not their bedroom so they can work quietly. In the survey data, only 49% of Americans have their own room that's not their bedroom, so most people are working from home in a room, meaning that their husband or wife
足以运行视频通话，高质量的视频通话。所以，对于我们这些住在城市好地段的人来说，这似乎完全是标准配置。你有很好的互联网，但许多较贫穷的城市地区或农村地区，他们有互联网，但信号时断时续，所以你无法真正进行视频通话。另一件事是家里的空间，所以那些能够成功实现居家办公的人，报告说他们有自己的房间，而不是卧室，这样他们就可以安静地工作。在调查数据中，只有49%的美国人拥有除卧室以外的独立房间，所以大多数人是在一个房间里居家办公，这意味着他们的丈夫或妻子……
in the same room or kids running around, etc cetera. So I just want to be, you know, very clear, COVID working from home is not great. Post COVID, I think, will be this Nevada where we're doing it, you know, two, one, two, three days a week. Our kids are back in school. We have proper equipment. We have a piece and quattro of our own room because, you know, our husband and wife, they're out of work and so we can get on with it. So what I hear you saying, of course, is that there is this massive worldwide experiment
在同一个房间里，或者孩子们跑来跑去等等。所以我只是想非常明确地说明，新冠疫情期间的居家办公并不理想。我认为，疫情之后将是一个新常态，我们每周会居家办公一、二、三天。我们的孩子回到学校了。我们有合适的设备。我们有自己安静的房间，因为我们的丈夫或妻子去上班了，所以我们可以继续工作。所以我听到你说的，当然是，这是一个巨大的全球性实验……
that is unfolding before our eyes. There's already some data starting to come in about its effects. I just read a paper by Lingfang Bao and colleagues. They analyze the effects of working from home arrangements as a result of COVID by examining productivity at Baidu, which is one of China's biggest IT companies, and they get mixed results. Some people report higher productivity, others, especially people
正在我们眼前展开。已经有一些关于其影响的数据开始出现。我刚读了一篇由Lingfang Bao及其同事撰写的论文。他们通过检查百度（中国最大的IT公司之一）的生产力，分析了新冠疫情导致的居家办公安排的影响，结果喜忧参半。有些人报告生产力提高，而另一些人，特别是那些……
working in big teams on complex or highly collaborative projects. They report lower productivity. Does that surprise you at all? No, I think the stories we're getting out from talking to firms and from the data is, what I would call day-to-day things, which is kind of continuing activities we've always been doing, which is a bit like, well, the folks I was talking about in C-tripped, they're basically making calls and taking bookings.
在大型团队中从事复杂或高度协作项目的人，他们报告生产力下降。这让你感到惊讶吗？不，我认为我们从与公司交谈和数据中得到的故事是，我称之为日常事务的东西，也就是我们一直在做的持续性活动，这有点像，嗯，我刚才提到的携程（C-trip）的员工，他们基本上是在打电话和处理预订。
That seems to work pretty well. So that, you're just, you know, repeating what you've done before, nothing too innovative, nothing too unusual or new, and you know, the piece and quite at home works quite well. What appears to be more of a struggle is more creative activities, bigger team group activities. So I'd say that's more long run.
这似乎效果很好。所以，你只是在重复你以前做过的事情，没有什么太创新的，没有什么太不寻常或新的，而且你知道，家里的安静环境效果相当好。看起来更困难的是更具创造性的活动，更大的团队小组活动。所以我说这更属于长期影响。
It's kind of like what, as economists, you might call intangible investments. And it goes back to quips, guys like Steve Jobs made, that, oh, they quote from Mr. May, you've really got to be in the building and talking to others, kicking back, you know, talking over the water cooler to come out with some of these ideas.
这有点像你们经济学家所说的无形投资。这回到了史蒂夫·乔布斯（Steve Jobs）等人所说的俏皮话，哦，他们引用梅先生（Mr. May）的话，你真的必须在办公楼里，与他人交谈，放松一下，在茶水间聊天，才能产生一些想法。
So I think in the short run, productivity is actually looking surprisingly good. What I worry about is innovation and creativity. For example, you know, next year's new iPhone, will that be that impressive? Because you know, all the innovation and research is going into it right now. I presume it's much harder to do working from home. Right.
所以我认为在短期内，生产力看起来实际上出奇地好。我担心的是创新和创造力。例如，明年的新iPhone会那么令人印象深刻吗？因为你知道，所有的创新和研究现在都在进行中。我推测居家办公要困难得多。对。
You mentioned Steve Jobs a second ago. This is almost a mantra in Silicon Valley, which is the chance and counters that happen when people work together. they bump into each other in the hallway and in the kitchens. Steve Jobs basically designed Apple to encourage chance encounters. So really the question that you're asking is what happens when you turn off that serendipity? Yeah, what's amazing is there's so much money invested by firms in this. You think of the billions and billions of dollars that high tech firms, but also investment banks,
你刚才提到了史蒂夫·乔布斯。这几乎是硅谷的口头禅，即人们一起工作时发生的偶然相遇。他们在走廊和厨房里撞见彼此。史蒂夫·乔布斯基本上设计了苹果公司来鼓励偶然相遇。所以你真正问的问题是，当你关闭那种机缘巧合时会发生什么？是的，令人惊奇的是，公司在这方面投入了大量的资金。想想高科技公司，还有投资银行投入的数十亿数十亿美元……
not a professional service firm, so spent on super fancy offices. They're trying to persuade people to come in. So the amazing artworks, the incredible free food, the ping pong table, the table football table, the astounding floor to ceiling glass, the incredible gardens, all of that floor to ceiling glass, the incredible gardens, all of that is to drag people into the office.
不是专业服务公司，而是花在超级豪华的办公室上。他们试图说服人们进来。所以那些令人惊叹的艺术品、令人难以置信的免费食物、乒乓球桌、桌上足球、令人震惊的落地玻璃、令人难以置信的花园，所有这些都是为了把人们拖进办公室。
Hi everyone, my name is Kevin and today we're going inside the multi-million dollar tree house conference room. Now, got a knot in your back, schedule a massage, looking for inspiration, attempt to talk with a road lead. We have our bike room. Our bike room holds 92 bikes. It's all about encouraging our employees to reduce their carbon footprint. First of all, you notice that you're getting a view and natural light, which is important. There's research that's shown how natural light and views help people focus and process information in a more effective way.
大家好，我叫凯文，今天我们要走进价值数百万美元的树屋会议室。现在，背部酸痛吗？预约按摩吧。寻找灵感吗？尝试与路人交谈。我们有自行车室。我们的自行车室可容纳92辆自行车。这一切都是为了鼓励我们的员工减少碳足迹。首先，你会注意到你拥有视野和自然光，这很重要。有研究表明，自然光和视野如何帮助人们更有效地集中注意力和处理信息。
I think it is important, you know, for my own experience honestly, just of I self-interrespect, a lot of my, you know, best research pieces have come from discussions over lunch and the year and conferences, but I think it is really important, but I must say that, you know, the research based on this is, is not entirely conclusive, and there's certainly fantastic creations that happen by people honestly working alone. You can come up with lots of examples of that too. Hmm, I'm wondering, I mean, the picture you're painting here,
我认为这很重要，老实说，从我自己的经验来看，通过自我反省，我的许多最好的研究成果都来自午餐时的讨论和会议期间的交流，但我认为这确实很重要，但我必须说，基于此的研究并不完全具有决定性，当然也有人们独自工作时产生的奇妙创造。你也可以举出很多这样的例子。嗯，我在想，我的意思是，你在这里描绘的图景……
if you asked me at the start of 2020, can 40% of the country work from home? I would have probably said, no, it would be very hard, probably impossible. And clearly now that's been proven on true, I think a large number of people are making it work. But I think the picture that's emerging from this conversation is how complex the question actually is,
如果你在2020年初问我，全国40%的人能居家办公吗？我可能会说，不，那会非常困难，甚至可能是不可能的。显然现在这已被证明是不正确的，我认为有大量的人正在使它行得通。但我认为这次谈话中出现的图景是这个问题实际上有多么复杂，
and how much it's connected to individual people's life situations. I mean, I've gotten to spend more time with family over the last few months as I'm working, which has been wonderful. But I can also imagine that people may perhaps who might not want to spend large amounts of time with family. Maybe they don't have a happy family situation, maybe they're single and living by themselves and it's extremely lonely.
以及它与个人生活状况的联系有多么紧密。我的意思是，过去几个月我能花更多时间与家人在一起，同时还在工作，这真是太棒了。但我也可以想象，有些人可能不想花大量时间与家人在一起。也许他们没有幸福的家庭状况，也许他们是单身，独自生活，感到非常孤独。
So the idea that there's a one-size-fits-all rule that's going to mean everyone working from home is more productive or everyone working from home is more unhappy, that simply breaks down, doesn't it? Exactly. So again, you see this so much in the survey data. So just to give you one figure, we ask people post COVID, how many days would you want to work from home? And 20% of people say none.
所以，认为有一个“一刀切”的规则，意味着每个人居家办公都更有效率，或者每个人居家办公都更不快乐，这显然是站不住脚的，不是吗？正是如此。所以，你在调查数据中再次看到了这一点。仅举一个数字，我们询问人们在新冠疫情后，你想居家办公多少天？20%的人说一天也不想。
You know, 20% of people do not want to work from home whatsoever. And they may be many of the types of people you mentioned, you know, they have very small apartments or they don't have great family situations Then there's 25% of people that want to work from home five days a week. They never want to go back to the office again And then the remaining 55% are a big spread. So this is something having, you know, work for years, all kinds of different parts of economics was such. I can't think of an area.'ve seen in such differing views. So the average person, if there's such a person, wants to work from home typically two days a week, but that average hides enormous variation.
你知道，20%的人根本不想居家办公。他们可能是你提到的许多类型的人，你知道，他们有非常小的公寓，或者他们的家庭状况不太好。然后有25%的人想每周居家办公五天。他们再也不想回到办公室了。剩下的55%则分布广泛。所以这是我工作多年来，在经济学的各个不同领域所见过的，我无法想象还有哪个领域有如此不同的观点。所以普通人，如果存在这样的人的话，通常想每周居家办公两天，但这个平均值掩盖了巨大的差异。
So I think the firm's choice is going to be absolutely essential to get this right. You know, I recently came by this part in the news on CNBC about the real estate market in New York City. Take a listen, Nick. The big worry here and the big numbers was this rapid rise in empty apartments, the inventory of rental listings soaring 85%, we now have a vacancy rate that is the highest in Manhattan on record. So Nick, beyond what happens to workers and companies,
所以我认为公司的选择对于正确处理这件事至关重要。你知道，我最近在CNBC的新闻中看到了关于纽约市房地产市场的部分。听听看，尼克。这里最大的担忧和巨大的数字是空置公寓的迅速增加，租赁房源的库存飙升了85%，我们现在的空置率是曼哈顿有记录以来的最高水平。所以尼克，除了对工人和公司发生的事情之外，
what do you think the effects of COVID and working from home might be on cities and where we decide to live? So I have to say, I think it's, you know, it's not good for cities. So just to be clear, there's plenty of people saying, well, cities have seen this all before, they always bounce back, there's been plenty of pandemics. That's true. But if you look, for example, you know, they bounce back, but they take a long time and
你认为新冠疫情和居家办公对城市以及我们决定居住的地方会有什么影响？所以我不得不说，我认为这……你知道，这对城市不利。所以要明确一点，有很多人说，嗯，城市以前都经历过这些，它们总是会反弹，有过很多次大流行病。这是真的。但如果你看看，例如，你知道，它们会反弹，但需要很长时间，而且……
in the words of Cain's, you know, John Maynard Cain's in the long run were all dead. So just as a, you know, what, one anecdote, if you look at London, I was watching something on CNN with somebody saying, you know, of course, London recovered after the plague. That's true, but if you look at the data 10 years after the Great Plague, 30% of buildings were still empty. So for the next 10 or 20 years, this is a, you know, a big blow for cities, particularly the center of cities. So the things that are most troubled are going to be these high-rise buildings, so 10-plus story buildings, because you can't get to them, you can't use the subway with social distancing.
用凯恩斯（John Maynard Keynes）的话说，从长远来看，我们都死了。所以作为一个轶事，如果你看看伦敦，我在CNN上看到有人说，你知道，当然，伦敦在瘟疫之后恢复了。这是真的，但如果你看看大瘟疫10年后的数据，30%的建筑物仍然是空的。所以未来10到20年，这对城市，特别是城市中心来说是一个巨大的打击。所以最受困扰的将是这些高层建筑，也就是10层以上的建筑，因为你无法到达它们，你无法在保持社交距离的情况下使用地铁。
And from the survey data I've seen, 70% of Americans report even post-COVID-Dead, be very nervous about getting into a pack subway train. And then once you're at the front door, you can't get up to, you know, higher stories because you can't get in the lift without, you know, of social distancing issues. So, you know, my prediction is prices will drop dramatically. It's not that skyscrapers are on apartments
而且根据我看到的调查数据，70%的美国人报告说即使在新冠疫情后，也会对进入拥挤的地铁列车感到非常紧张。一旦你到了前门，你就无法到达更高的楼层，因为你无法在没有社交距离问题的情况下进入电梯。所以，你知道，我的预测是价格会大幅下跌。并不是说摩天大楼或公寓……
or remain empty from the clip they are right now, but I wouldn't be surprised to see prices of say Manhattan, you know, apartment and office buildings falling by 30 to 50 percent, and that's the way you keep them, I keep them. I'm not sure it's a bad thing because it's re-backed. It would take us back to say 2000, or rebalance a bit the country. Rural areas have been left behind, and the center of cities have done incredibly well. If we rewind that by 20 years back to 2000, you have just a more balanced national setup without such an affordability crisis in the center of cities.
会像现在这样保持空置，但我不会对曼哈顿公寓和办公楼价格下跌30%到50%感到惊讶，这就是你保持它们的方式。我不确定这是一件坏事，因为它会重新平衡。它会把我们带回2000年左右，或者稍微重新平衡一下这个国家。农村地区被抛在了后面，而城市中心做得非常好。如果我们把时间倒回20年前到2000年，你会有一个更平衡的国家格局，而城市中心就不会有如此严重的负担能力危机。
So it's obviously about two, there's a fork in the road that's coming up. So let's say optimistically that there's a good vaccine that comes along. And all of us feel much safer about COVID than we do right now. And everyone technically can go back to work as we did in the old days, into workplaces. It could also be that the changes that we're seeing now somehow become permanent because either companies
所以这显然是关于二选一，前方有一个岔路口。那么，让我们乐观地假设有一种好的疫苗出现。我们所有人都比现在感觉对新冠疫情更安全。每个人在技术上都可以像过去那样回到工作岗位，进入工作场所。也可能我们现在看到的这些变化以某种方式变得永久化，因为公司……
decide it makes sense for them. Employees decide it makes sense for them. Cities and communities are organized differently. Which way do you think we're going to go Nick? So after COVID is in the rearview mirror, do you think we're going to go back to the way things were before? No, I'm pretty sure most of this will be permanent. So you know, I can give you, there are four reasons that are driving permanence. Firstly, this has turned out to be a great experience in the sense that 70% of companies have reported work and foam has turned out better than predicted.
决定这对他们有意义。员工决定这对他们有意义。城市和社区的组织方式不同。你认为我们会走向哪条路，尼克？所以新冠疫情成为过去式后，你认为我们会回到以前的样子吗？不，我很确定大部分变化将是永久性的。所以你知道，我可以给你四个驱动永久性的原因。首先，事实证明这是一次很棒的经历，70%的公司报告说居家办公的结果比预期的要好。
So they're much more enthusiastic. Secondly, the stigma seems to have evaporated. So again, in survey data, three quarters of people report their perception is a big drop in stigma. Thirdly investment, so we collected data and the average person in America has invested 12 hours and about a thousand dollars Setting up working from home. So you know to take me personally, I spent a while figuring out how all these you know doom and Teams and time and everything works and I bought a proper webcam and a mic and you know tried to organize the room a bit
所以他们更加热情。其次，污名似乎已经消失了。所以同样，在调查数据中，四分之三的人报告说他们的感知是污名大幅下降。第三是投资，所以我们收集了数据，美国普通人已经投入了12个小时和大约1000美元来建立居家办公环境。所以你知道，就我个人而言，我花了一些时间弄清楚所有这些Zoom、Teams、Time等是如何工作的，我买了一个合适的网络摄像头和麦克风，并试图整理一下房间……
And then finally social distancing so as I mentioned there is still plenty of concern from individuals that even post COVID vaccine. There are nervous about getting in elevate, packed elevators and mass transit. And so will be reluctant to come in. And you can see why there's, you know, COVID was obviously terrible, but there's been near misses, SARS and Ebola and MERS and bird flu, etc. So I think my prediction is just to put figures on it actually is before COVID, 5% of working days in America were full time at home. During COVID, it's about 40% so 40% of working days are at home, post COVID from talking to firms and from our service, it looks something like 20%. So we're going to, you know, wind back a bit from where we are now because, you know, no one's going
最后是社交距离，正如我提到的，即使在新冠疫苗接种后，人们仍然有很多担忧。他们对进入电梯、拥挤的电梯和公共交通感到紧张。因此会不愿进来。你可以看出为什么会有，你知道，新冠疫情显然很可怕，但之前有近距离接触，SARS、埃博拉、MERS和禽流感等等。所以我认为我的预测，实际上是给它加上数字，在新冠疫情之前，美国5%的工作日是全职在家。在新冠疫情期间，大约是40%，所以40%的工作日是在家，新冠疫情后，从与公司交谈和我们的调查来看，看起来大约是20%。所以我们将从现在的位置稍微回撤一点，因为你知道，没有人会……
to be full time at home or very few people, but we're well above wind back a bit from where we are now, because no one's going to be full time at home or very few people, but we're well above what we were before COVID. Mm. I'm wondering, Nick, if you're hiring an employee, maybe you are less interested is the employee in the same zip code as I am, or in the same city as I am. Maybe now if you're a company, you actually
全职在家，或者很少有人会，但我们远高于新冠疫情之前的水平。嗯。我在想，尼克，如果你在招聘员工，也许你对员工是否与我在同一个邮政编码区或同一个城市不太感兴趣。也许现在如果你是一家公司，你实际上……
can hire more widely. Maybe you can actually look to rural areas or even other countries for labor in ways that you couldn't earlier. In other words, it actually might unleash a lot of people who previously could not find their way to an expensive Manhattan job interview. Now can actually be in the running for that job. No, exactly. I think this is going to be great for rebalance in the economy.
可以更广泛地招聘。也许你实际上可以寻找农村地区甚至其他国家的劳动力，这是你以前无法做到的。换句话说，它实际上可能会释放出许多以前无法找到去昂贵的曼哈顿面试机会的人。现在可以真正参与该职位的竞争。不，正是如此。我认为这对重新平衡经济将是非常棒的。
So many of what I see, the political, you know, troubles in the US and also my homeland, the UK are from this increasing, growing rural urban divide. And the rural parts of the country felt left behind, you know, felt forgotten about by urban elites, et cetera. Now, if suddenly we allow both people to move out of cities into the countryside, but also jobs to move. So even if nobody moves, if employers can now hire people in rural areas more easily, that's going to rebalance things. And so you can imagine if we're working from home, let's say three days a week and only
所以我看到的许多美国以及我的祖国英国的政治麻烦，都源于这种日益增长的城乡鸿沟。农村地区感到被抛在后面，你知道，感到被城市精英等遗忘了。现在，如果突然间我们允许人们搬出城市进入乡村，同时也允许工作岗位转移。所以即使没有人搬家，如果雇主现在能更容易地在农村地区招聘人员，那将重新平衡一切。所以你可以想象，如果我们居家办公，比如说每周三天，只……
coming in the office two days a week, you can be recruiting people far out deep into rural areas. So if a Stanford professor like you can work at Stanford but pay rent in let's say Kansas or in or in Wahaka, Mexico, why would someone like you choose to live in Palo Alto? Well, this comes back to, you know, I guess, inertia. I mean, it's a good question. If, you know, imagine COVID lasts, you know, the pandemic horrifically lasted for five years. A lot of people will be asking themselves that question,
每周在办公室工作两天，你可以从遥远的农村地区招聘人员。所以如果像你这样的斯坦福大学教授可以在斯坦福工作，但支付堪萨斯州或墨西哥瓦哈卡州的租金，为什么像你这样的人会选择住在帕洛阿尔托？嗯，这回到了，你知道，我想，惯性。我的意思是，这是一个好问题。如果，你知道，想象一下新冠疫情持续了，你知道，大流行病可怕地持续了五年。很多人会问自己那个问题，
why am I living in such expensive areas? You know, it works for us living here, my kids are in local schools, and you know, we have friends locally, et cetera. But I guess if it's lasted forever, and again, just to be clear, post pandemic, which I hope and think is going to be potentially say a year away when a vaccine comes out, I see us going back into the office two, three days a week. But there are certain jobs, I think, it's become clear that they can just be done entirely remotely. And for those jobs, you may well see a lot of people moved, you know, you might live in Hawaii, you might live
为什么我住在这么昂贵的地方？你知道，这对我们住在这里的人来说很有效，我的孩子在当地学校上学，而且你知道，我们在当地有朋友等等。但我猜如果它永远持续下去，再次明确一下，大流行病之后，我希望并认为可能是一年之后，当疫苗出来时，我看到我们回到办公室工作两三天。但有些工作，我认为，已经很清楚它们可以完全远程完成。对于这些工作，你很可能会看到很多人搬家，你知道，你可能住在夏威夷，你可能住在……
next to the beach and then I, you know, code for Facebook. And there's nothing wrong with that. And if that works out, actually, that's great. You may fly to, you know, Silicon Valley once every other month to meet in person and spend the rest of your time living out in Hawaii or, you know, living up in the ski slope. So I think we'll see a big increase in that. And in fact, if you look look if you look at the reports from real estate agents They are talking about there's been an explosion of people are wanting to buy what's called lifestyle properties So you know beautiful branches deep at the countryside that you know You can buy a small man hat in the apartment or you can buy a 200 acre lunch at and Wyoming and if you can work remotely
海滩旁边，然后我，你知道，为Facebook写代码。这没什么错。如果这行得通，实际上，那太棒了。你可能会每隔一个月飞往硅谷一次，亲自见面，其余时间住在夏威夷，或者，你知道，住在滑雪坡上。所以我认为我们会看到这种情况大幅增加。事实上，如果你看看房地产经纪人的报告，他们谈到人们想要购买所谓的“生活方式房产”的人数出现了爆炸式增长。所以你知道，深处乡村的美丽牧场，你知道，你可以买一个小曼哈顿公寓，或者你可以买一个怀俄明州的200英亩牧场，如果你能远程工作……
You know, maybe you go for the lat. But again, you have this divide, don't you, which is that this is speaking now to the people who are the wealthiest people who are able to think that way. And if you don't have the education, the technology, the support from an employer to do this, there's really gonna be this bifurcating caste system.
你知道，也许你会选择后者。但同样，你面临这种鸿沟，不是吗？那就是这现在是在对那些最有钱、能够那样思考的人说话。如果你没有教育、技术、雇主的支持来做到这一点，真的会形成这种分化的种姓制度。
Yes, although I think in terms of moving people out to rural areas, it pushes them both directions. You're exactly right. is bifurcating caste system. Yes, although I think in terms of moving people out to rural areas, it pushes them both directions. You're exactly right. The people who can work from home are educated and so they gain a lot of the direct benefits. It is true though, if a lot of say wealthy New Yorkers move out into the countryside, when they're out there
是的，尽管我认为在将人们转移到农村地区方面，它将他们推向了两个方向。你是完全正确的。是分化的种姓制度。是的，尽管我认为在将人们转移到农村地区方面，它将他们推向了两个方向。你是完全正确的。那些能居家办公的人受过教育，所以他们获得了许多直接的好处。不过，如果许多富有的纽约人搬到乡村，当他们在那里时……
going to demand services, restaurants and go out to gyms, et cetera, and no doubt pay more tax revenue. They're improved local schools. And so that will indirectly spill over to people that are out that maybe can't work from home, but will get some of the indirect benefits. So the inequality impacts a bit mixed. I think it will really reduce an equality
他们会要求服务、餐馆和去健身房等等，毫无疑问会支付更多的税收收入。他们改善了当地学校。因此，这将间接溢出到那些可能无法居家办公但会获得一些间接好处的人身上。所以不平等的影响有点复杂。我认为它真的会减少不平等……
if we can rebalance things a bit away from cities. It's not like, I was born in London. I lived in London until I was 30. I'm basically a city person, but it's also clear that even for me, one of the reasons I left London and came out to the US is it was just too expensive to live in. And I think it will be better for society cities, or, you know, not so unbelievably expensive. So you could have a more mixed set of people lived in them. And there's more, you know, basically diversity across the US, rather than becoming so geographically segregated
如果我们能稍微从城市重新平衡一下。并不是说，我出生在伦敦。我在伦敦住到30岁。我基本上是一个城市人，但也很清楚，即使对我来说，我离开伦敦来到美国的原因之一就是生活太贵了。我认为这对社会城市会更好，或者，你知道，不会那么令人难以置信地昂贵。所以你可以让更多样化的人群住在里面。而且美国各地基本上有更多的多样性，而不是变得如此地理隔离……
by income, which is what's been happening until recently. Hmm. What's been your most embarrassing work from home or been these last few months? Ah. Oh. Um, my most embarrassing work. I mean, I tell you one, this is the classic early days of Zoom.
按收入划分，这正是最近发生的事情。嗯。这几个月你最尴尬的居家办公经历是什么？啊。哦。嗯。我最尴尬的工作。我的意思是，我告诉你一个，这是Zoom早期的经典案例。
I was on a video call, it was a Zoom call, and I screen shared with some a couple of co-authors, and I've forgotten to turn off screen sharing, and at some point one of them is talking, and as you do, was losing concentration and went to start doing some emails and was typing or reply. And my co-authors suddenly said, Nick, you do realize you're still on screen, Chef. And he'd very politely taken a while thinking I might turn back, but you know, for the last five, six minutes, you must have been, maybe even ten minutes, watching me type e-mars out and clearly paying no attention.
我在进行视频通话，那是Zoom通话，我和几个合著者共享了屏幕，我忘了关闭屏幕共享，在某个时候其中一个人在说话，正如你所做的那样，我失去了注意力，开始处理一些电子邮件，正在打回复。我的合著者突然说，尼克，你意识到你还在屏幕共享吗？他非常有礼貌地花了一段时间，以为我可能会转回来，但你知道，在过去的五、六分钟，甚至可能是十分钟里，你一定一直在看我打电子邮件，显然根本没在听。
One of the things you have to realise when you are working from home is the office norms just don't apply. So it's completely reasonable if you're working from home to have a cat walk across your camera or a baby crying in the background and one of my colleagues just had a baby and you know that baby is often sitting in his lap during conference calls and he is cute and it is the way it is in the office it would seem weird but I like the fact that working from home there's a new set of rules around what's reasonable. rules around what's reasonable. Economist Nick Bloom teaches at Stanford.
当你居家办公时，你必须意识到的一件事是办公室规范根本不适用。所以如果你居家办公，让猫走过你的摄像头或背景里有婴儿哭闹是完全合理的，我的一位同事刚生了孩子，你知道那个孩子在电话会议期间经常坐在他的腿上，他很可爱，事实就是这样。在办公室里这看起来会很奇怪，但我喜欢居家办公的事实是，关于什么是合理的，有一套新的规则。关于什么是合理的规则。经济学家尼克·布鲁姆（Nick Bloom）在斯坦福大学任教。
Or to be more precise, he teaches from his spare bedroom and sometimes from his bathroom when his kids are practicing the backbipes. Nick Bloom, thank you for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Thanks, it's been fantastic fantastic thank you for having me. The concern is that they want to have a Kurdish excuse me my kids are here live television. Cold air continues across the area tonight potential for some frost and freeze for some of us warm up it's going to take. Maple David Cameron was talking about oh I'm really sorry that's my son arriving sorry really very sorry
或者更准确地说，他在他的备用卧室里教书，有时在他的浴室里，当他的孩子们在练习风笛时。尼克·布鲁姆，感谢你今天加入“隐藏的大脑”（Hidden Brain）。谢谢，这太棒了，谢谢你邀请我。担心的是他们想有一个库尔德语……对不起，我的孩子们在这里，直播电视。冷空气今晚继续穿过该地区，我们有些人可能会有霜冻和结冰，回暖需要时间。枫树大卫·卡梅伦（David Cameron）在谈论……哦，我真的很抱歉，那是我的儿子到了，抱歉，真的很抱歉。
Yes I'm really sorry. Yeah, okay, well less will leave. All right, welcome back. I'm going to be back in studio on Monday, so I thought I'd bring my daughter, Alina, with us. It's a no. Hey, can you say it's going to be sunny today? No, it's going to be hot. OK, good work. Lots of upper 80s and low 90s over the next seven
是的，我真的很抱歉。是的，好吧，莱斯会离开。好的，欢迎回来。我周一会回到演播室，所以我以为我会带我的女儿阿丽娜（Alina）一起来。这是一个不。嘿，你能说今天会是晴天吗？不，会很热。好的，干得好。未来七天会有很多80多度到90多度的天气……
since 10 days. This didn't go as planned, Jackie. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Midrall Media is our exclusive advertising sales partner. Our audio production team includes Bridget McCarthy, Laura Correll, Autumn Barnes and Andrew Chadwick. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor. Special thanks this week to our former producer, Thomas Liu.
10天。这没有按计划进行，杰基。“隐藏的大脑”由“隐藏的大脑媒体”（Hidden Brain Media）制作。Midrall Media是我们独家的广告销售合作伙伴。我们的音频制作团队包括布里奇特·麦卡锡（Bridget McCarthy）、劳拉·科雷尔（Laura Correll）、奥特姆·巴恩斯（Autumn Barnes）和安德鲁·查德威克（Andrew Chadwick）。塔拉·博伊尔（Tara Boyle）是我们的执行制片人。我是“隐藏的大脑”的执行编辑。本周特别感谢我们以前的制片人托马斯·刘（Thomas Liu）。
Our unsung hero today is someone who has made it possible for the Hidden Brain team to work from home successfully. His name is Yitbaraq Adafene and he's a business expert with Apple in Washington DC. When our show moved to independent production earlier this fall, we needed new computers. Yet, as he's known, patiently walked me through the process of setting up a business account for our new company and ensured we got our computers on a tight turnaround. It helped that he is something of an audiophile himself.
我们今天的无名英雄是让“隐藏的大脑”团队能够成功居家办公的人。他的名字是Yitbaraq Adafene，他是华盛顿特区苹果公司的商业专家。今年秋天早些时候，当我们的节目转向独立制作时，我们需要新的电脑。Yet，正如他所知，耐心地引导我完成了为我们新公司设置商业账户的过程，并确保我们在紧迫的时间内拿到了电脑。他自己也是个音响发烧友，这很有帮助。
It's no exaggeration to say that if you enjoyed the episodes we put out in October, you have yet to thank. Thank you yet. For more hidden brain, follow us on Facebook, Twitter, or at hiddenbrain.org. If you like this episode and like our show, please tell your friends. If they don't know how to subscribe to our podcast, please show them. Thanks for listening. I'm Shankar Vedanta. Thanks for listening. I'm Shankar Vedanta. Thanks for listening.
毫不夸张地说，如果你喜欢我们在十月份发布的剧集，你必须感谢Yet。谢谢你，Yet。欲了解更多“隐藏的大脑”内容，请在Facebook、Twitter或hiddenbrain.org上关注我们。如果你喜欢这一集并喜欢我们的节目，请告诉你的朋友。如果他们不知道如何订阅我们的播客，请教教他们。感谢收听。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆（Shankar Vedanta）。感谢收听。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。感谢收听。
Thanks for listening. I'm Shankar Vedanta. Thanks for listening. Thanks for listening. Thanks for listening. Thanks for listening. Thanks for listening. Thanks for listening.
感谢收听。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。感谢收听。感谢收听。感谢收听。感谢收听。感谢收听。感谢收听。
Thanks for listening. Thanks for listening. Thanks for listening. Thanks for listening. Thanks for listening. Thanks for listening. Thanks for listening. Thanks for listening. Thanks for listening. Thanks for listening.
感谢收听。感谢收听。感谢收听。感谢收听。感谢收听。感谢收听。感谢收听。感谢收听。感谢收听。感谢收听。
Thanks for listening. Thanks for listening. Thanks for listening. Thanks for listening. Thanks for listening. Thanks for listening. Thanks for listening. Thanks for listening. Where you at? The last part of that should be pretty good. I don't know how long you wanted. Great. How long did you want? There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
感谢收听。感谢收听。感谢收听。感谢收听。感谢收听。感谢收听。感谢收听。感谢收听。你在哪？那部分的最后应该相当不错。我不知道你想要多长。太棒了。你想要多长？这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。